why are so many people leaving the NHS
it is a complex organization so it is a
complex answer but the data shows us
some of the various reasons let's start
with work life balance this chart shows
people who've left the service on top of
what we'd expect if resignation rates
had stayed the same and you can see that
work-life balance in red is well over
and above the other reasons relocation
or health for example with that
increased costing the NHS 10 000 Staff
last year staff across the NHS now three
times more likely to quit due to
work-life balance than they were a
decade ago and we can see that strain in
another set of figures people taking
time off work due to stress anxiety or
depression that is a 56 increase since
2015 nearly half a million days off for
mental health or one in every 80 working
days so a worse work-life balance worse
mental health problems and on top of
that less pay for example adjusting for
inflation over the last 10 years and
nursing assistant day has been pretty
flat but compare that with a switchboard
operator or a warehouse worker they're
paid going up you can see why some NHS
workers might consider moving jobs and
brexit is another reason the NHS has
been losing staff a recent study by the
Northfield trust found the number of
European health workers moving to the UK
has declined steeply since the 2016
referendum now for some areas like
nursing it's managed to fill those gaps
from outside the EU but it is a
different story for some medical
specialisms like surgeons and he has
since brexit the number of doctors
recruited from every sector here the EU
and elsewhere is less than it was before
but much less from that blue of the
European Union the UK is training more
new recruits at home though it has been
for a while for the last two decades the
UK has produced more medical graduates
than the average oecd country yet it
still lags behind in terms of practicing
doctors per population that's mainly
because of lack of training posts after
graduation let you leave you with this
which shows the growing problem we hear
about more doctors adding the workforce
expanding and it has by 179 000 in the
last four years but the growing demands
that there is this Gap and that Gap is
why we have a crisis because vacancies
are rising not falling